there were three major covid domains as
we encountered them one covet domain had
to do with the origin of covet itself
the other two had to do with the utility
of early treatment drugs like ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine
and the third had to do with the safety
and effectiveness of vaccines right now
in all three of these we could talk
about what it is that the fringe spotted
that you know the fringe had been
actively driven to the fringe that
actually there were things that the
mainstream should have been talking
about that it wasn't interested in
talking about
one thing that is true is that the
fringe gets defined by taking a position
that runs counter to whatever prevailing
forces are running the establishment so
there were a lot of scientists
researchers health professionals who
two years ago two and a half years ago
five years ago uh thought that and
appeared to be completely within the
mainstream in terms of you know doing
good work doing honest work having
integrity uh pursuing evidence as it you
know pursuing evidence as it showed up
and figuring out what it meant and if a
what then you know what to be if given a
and um we're pushed into we're vilified
we're named as people on the outside
because they arrived at conclusions that
didn't fit it's not that they were they
were or many people were not already on
the outside nor were these people who
were looking to be
fringe 2b contrarian
be outside of you know the the the
civilized discourse of cocktail parties
there are certainly people like that um
but this is not the driving thing the
driving the driving thing is
what's true what are we doing oh my god
there's this there's this evolving
situation quite literally on many levels
what is true of it and therefore what
can we do to better ourselves um in the
face of you know coven two years ago and
to prepare for such a thing in the
future what is the likelihood of such a
thing and what is this thing what is the
nature of the thing right and in fact um
one of the things that tells you that
covid is an incredibly screwed up i
would argue upside down landscape
is the high quality of the people who
are supposedly french
right so you've got you know tess lori
uh
on a test laurie and john campbell on
iremecht and tess lori literally being
uh a highly decorated who scientist
you've got um pierre cory you know who
has you know literally written a
textbook on pulmonology and is a highly
decorated icu doc
right you've got um one of the world's
most published cardiologists
uh peter mccullough
you have um you know
literally one of the uh
arguably the primary architect of the
mrna technology that went into vaccines
raising alarm about these mrna vaccines
you really couldn't ask for more highly
qualified people right but nonetheless
they are portrayed as if they are fringe
um
in fact we will get we will get back to
sam here a little bit later but sam
actually wondered aloud sam harris
wondered aloud in in one of his podcasts
on the subject whether the explanation
for these people was that they were
simply part of the small percentage of
the society that's schizophrenic well
and this actually um
because because we have so much to talk
about let me just slip in here something
that i thought we might spend more time
on but
um
luke montagne
died in february uh he was a nobel
laureate he received the nobel in
2008
i want to say um
it was a co-recipient
uh and
he and she shared it with someone else
and i'm not just not remaining the
specifics
but
he shared it
with gosh i've forgotten her name for
the discovery of of hiv
and
there have certainly been people who
received the
nobel
who later on
people came to think i'm not not so sure
about that
the fact that luke montagne
came to question some of
what he had understood to be true later
on
and what indeed whether or not
hiv was
the sole
cause of aids which is certainly not a
mainstream position and it's not
accepted within the establishment but he
was pursuing evidence he didn't say you
have to listen to me this is the only
way to proceed he said i'm i am
wondering about this and in covid
uh he he came out early
by in actually talking about lab leak he
said i i cannot i cannot comprehend
given what i've seen of this virus and a
lifetime of research on viruses and
indeed as a nobel laureate that this
particular virus could have a zoonotic
origin i uh and so he uh
he certainly was well outside the
mainstream and he has other other
positions that are well outside the
mainstream
um on covid
but at the point that he died
the obituaries were a slow incoming
and uh either so benul as to be clearly
disrespectful in that regard or
um or actually disrespectful so let me
let me just say this i'm going to point
to
this
i chose i said to us to you earlier i
chose the wrong week to
switch to brave because nothing is quite
simple anymore
let me see if i can find it here we go
okay
here's a
an obit in science on one of the two
premier science journals
in the world
published just two days ago even though
he died in early february so that that
in itself is quite something
it's quite a short obituary it has um
really nothing about his controversial
positions
and it ends
with this
line
as bjorn wenstrum i don't know i don't
remember who that is remarked at the
2008 nobel ceremony montagnier was in
the right place at the right time
that is so nasty it's so nasty and this
is how
when someone has
gotten so many accolades that it's
really hard to make them into the fringe
this this is fringe making yeah that's
that's what that is so that's that's
it's hard coding the analysis that luke
montagne is fringe that his success
which nobody disputes
is the result of luck right right
and he was surrounded by good people
right and he got lucky and let me tell
you something scientifically speaking
right we all of us who actually get how
science works understands that it's a
self-correcting process and so this idea
that science has arrived somewhere and
we are all to follow it is [ __ ] from
the get-go
um but the basic point is look
when somebody with a nobel prize a
relevant nobel prize takes up a
heterodox position especially one with a
high social cost
right you don't necessarily know that
that person is right but you do know
that you would need to know a lot
in order to dismiss them right so
let's just say okay you've got luke
montagne one of his positions
you know
the thing for which he got the prize the
discovery of hiv right his later change
of position involved his
uh
emerging belief that hiv the virus that
he discovered which nobody disagrees
exists
is a co-traveler with aids and not
causal so his new belief
down regulates downgrades the importance
of the discovery for which he got the
nobody of his own contribution right so
in a court we would call that like
statement against interest right you're
more likely to believe this because it's
not something you would be expected to
say because it's good for you to say it
right right so okay that's interesting
does the fact that a
somebody who you know is capable enough
to get a nobel prize would reach this
uh paradoxical conclusion about the very
thing for which they got the prize
that's interesting even more interesting
when you get to the fact that uh he
wasn't the only nobel laureate to reach
that conclusion right right kerry mullis
who also recently died and also was on
the other side
he he died at the very beginning maybe
even just before before covid um but he
had already ended up on the wrong side
of anthony fauci right
he
was alarmed by anthony fauci and he was
also alarmed by the
uh
use of his invention
for
uh for testing for things like viruses
because he knew pcr to be so sensitive
that the cycle threshold issue made it
possible to abuse it very easily it was
not an appropriate diagnostic tool he
won the nobel for the
i guess we would say invention in the
case of polymerase chain reaction as
opposed to the discovery um in the case
of montagne's prize of hiv and actually
there's a connection this is a
connection that will come back uh
in a few minutes if i can remember it um
but the connection is
like many of our best tricks in medicine
pcr is
yes it's an invention and a brilliant
one but it is borrowed almost entirely
from nature right right well that's why
i sort of pause and like it's it's an
invention um but but it uses it it's
inspired by and uses many of the tricks
that nature has used let's put it this
way its primary tools are enzymes that
we could not have written yeah right
yeah not even close we just borrowed
them from nature and they do what they
do and you know they can be modified but
uh but we just don't know enough to do
it
okay so
we've got this process of
fringe making right that has nothing to
do it's you know actually you know what
it is it's an exact parallel to that
thing we just described right this is
the manufacture of an artificial fringe
like in the center of something right
it's like you've got a carpet and you
decide to put a fringe somewhere in the
middle of it in order that people don't
pay attention to the stain or whatever
right
because
these people aren't french yeah right
now again you don't know whether luke
montagne
knows something
far beyond what you understand at the
point he says no no hiv is not causing
aids you don't know whether he's goofed
right or he's got some deep insight but
what you do know is that you can't
casually dismiss it especially in light
of the fact that he's going after he won
the nobel he's out of kook territory
he
could be a kook right the point is
a what gets you to that level in science
is something unusual so at the point he
says something really unusual and
counter-intuitive especially something
that
downgrades the importance of his own
discovery right you have to listen and
then at the point that you find another
heterodox
nobel laureate right who has reached the
same conclusion
still doesn't make them right but it
does mean hey how much would you have to
know before you were in a position to
say these people
they
they've lost the threat right right
you'd have to look you'd have to know a
ton but instead the point is oh well
that's a crazy everybody knows hiv
causes aids i was like well okay
everybody knows that but you're now it
you know it's rather a lot like uh
robert malone right
you want to say robert malone doesn't
know what he's talking about with
respect to the safety of these vaccines
really then who does
right you know if anybody is likely to
have insight
it would be robert malone and if anybody
was likely to be corrupt in the
direction of thinking that they were
safer than they are you'd expect it to
be malone because that would make his
invention that much more useful well
there are a lot of these slights of hand
and they they all have some
there's some differences between them
but another one that comes to mind is
well everyone knows that vares isn't
reliable that the you know vaccine
adverse event reporting system isn't
reliable like oh well then what are we
using right
oh we don't have anything but that
like
okay if we accept the well everyone
knows that
uh initial like you can ignore the man
behind the curtain part of the argument
um there's almost always a like well
then who or what or
you know on what basis do you know that
you know they did exactly this thing to
me on the mice too i every time i tried
to raise this issue about hey you've
created an evolutionary environment in
your mouse breeding colonies that has
created mice that are lying to you and
telling you that drugs are safe right
yup i got back it's amazing how often
people were like everybody knows the
mice are broken
and it's like look first of all if
everyone knows the mice are broken and
you're using them for drug safety
testing then that's on you second of all
there's no reason they have to be broken
this way i can tell you how to fix the
evolutionary environment in those
colonies and the point is you're not
interested because you just feel like
well i'm in the know like everybody else
you know and you're on the fringe and
it's like no the fringe is in the center
of the goddamn carpet well then again i
mean that it's it's a social argument as
opposed to an argument about reality or
about or about science right like
you're telling me something i already
knew
maybe
but two things right like you were in
fact telling them
you were you were telling them something
they already knew but with so much more
precision that you could actually you
actually had a solution for it and
and
the idea that
because they knew something in that
territory in advance
doesn't clear them of the responsibility
for therefore basing all of their
science on a bad model
well
i was telling them something that they
could plausibly dismiss as something
they knew right they didn't really know
it right the fact of the telomere
elongation a which didn't have to happen
that was the result of them not
realizing that a colony is an
evolutionary environment and not
realizing that it was going to have a
particular
effect but the point is yes all models
are imperfect right a mouse is not a
person there are going to be ways in
which a mouse is an imperfect model for
people we all know that um the fact that
it's broken in a particular way
especially a solvable way right you have
to be a fool to dismiss the insight into
how it's broken because if you could fix
it you know if everybody knows the mice
are broken then wouldn't it be cool to
have some mice that were less broken
right you know so anyway it's a it's an
interesting i guess the point is it's
all specific versions of a very generic
game right the powerful people are
constantly
fringing
their
detractors right no matter how central
those detractors are in the case of
you know corey tess laurie
uh peter mccullough robert malone
but anyway that's a process of like
forcibly
uh painting someone as a fringe when
that's not not what they are
[Music]